Let us use the assignment of car as the conveyance,
to illustrate how these different words get assigned to different categories,
different slots in this frame. Now,
we know that car was a conveyance because of the role that this preposition, by,
plays here. That is, an intelligent agent might make use of the structure of
the sentence to make sense of the story. We have designed human language in such
a way that there is a particular structure to them. Prepositions, for instance,
play a very important role. Here are some of the common prepositions: by, for,
from, to, with. Each preposition plays certain thematic roles.
By can be an, by an agent, or by a conveyance, or by a location. Similarly for
the other prepositions. So the moment we see by, here we know that,
whatever is going to come after by, the care can be a agent, or a conveyance, or
a location. Note again that the categories we are using here
are semantic categories, we are not saying noun, or verb or
anything like that, what we are saying here is beneficiary and duration, and
source which are semantic categories, that allow us to draw inferences. But
how did we know that car was a conveyance, and not an agent, or a location?
In general, while the structure of language does provide constraints, these
constraints do not always definitely determine the meaning of that particular
word. We'll use additional knowledge to find the exact meaning of the word car.